-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well.
Let's get to the news.
The National Guard yesterday
began withdrawing troops
from the U.S. Capitol followin
a five-month deployment
after the January insurrection
Which is strange,
considering they didn't even get
all the insurrectionists
out, yet.
The White House announced
today that the U.S. has
officially vaccinated 50%
of its adult population
and they expect that,
by the end of September,
they will have vaccinated
the other 7% or 8%.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, the White Hous
announced today that the U.S
has officially vaccinated
50% of the adult population,
as well as one 11-year-old
with a mustache.
[ Laughter ]
"Uh, could I get a Moderna
and a case of
Mike's Hard Lemonade?
[ Laughter ]
Whose Schwinn is that outside?
So lame!"
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
is expected to meet
with Russian President
Vladimir Putin
next month in Switzerland
for their first
face-to-face summit
or, you know, face-to-chest.
I just hope it does not come
down to a staring contest
because both of those guys
have had a lot of Botox.
Could be a long one.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
announced yesterday
that Secretary of State
Tony Blinken
will travel this week to Israe
to discuss the cease-fire
between Israel and Hamas.
Okay, can we send someone
a little more intimidating
Tony Blinken looks like a gu
who thinks your mom's
a real special lady,
but isn't trying
to replace your dad.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Governor Ron DeSanti
yesterday signed a law
regulating social media
companies' moderation
of user speech.
Said Twitter,
"Sir, that's just --
it's just spell-check."
Vice President Kamala Harris
said yesterday
that broadband Internet is
"critical to infrastructure"
and then, Spectrum added
a 30-cent critical
to infrastructure fee.
[ Laughter ]
Google announced last week
it will open its first-eve
physical retail store
this summer in New York
and get this --
Tinder already did.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Google announced last week
it will open its first-eve
physical retail store
this summer in New York,
although, it will be weird
to ask a salesperson a questio
and get 1.3 million answers.
[ Laughter ]
A Florida woman who was wearin
nearly no clothing
was arrested over the weeken
after she allegedly stole a ca
and led authorities
on a high-speed chase.
And to give you an idea
what Florida's like,
the police in Florida refe
to that as a code 1.
A bank robbery is a code 2
According to new research,
a day on Venus lasts
nearly 6,000 hours.
"So, same as Earth?"
asked Amazon workers.
And, finally, producers have
announced that a documentary
about lifestyle expert
Martha Stewart
will stream on Netflix.
And, if you don't have
a Netflix account,
she'll show you how to make on
out of driftwood and corn husks.
And that was a monologue.